Captain Marvel! Ms. Marvel!
And the marvelous Monica,
Self Promotion Anyone?!? together
at last! How could it go wrong?
Congratulations, you have finally
asked a relevant question.
The MCU's latest chapter has us
marveling at all the wrong things,
Last time I trusted someone, I lost an eye.
while Marvel Studios panics over box
office returns. How about we just make
a good movie! What made this mashup
such a misfire? Let us count the ways.
And a warning if you're curious:
we're spoiling everything ahead.
The Marvel Studios logo used to really mean
something. For audiences, it was a sign of
quality, or at least a sign that Robert Downey
Jr. might show up and make some naughty jokes.
Let’s face it, this is not the worst
thing you have caught me doing.
For the film industry, that logo was a
warning sign – it meant "our movie is
going to open to at least $80 million, so
back off – this weekend is ours. F–k you,
'Best Exotic Marigold Hotel!' We have a Hulk!"
I feel like I am on my deathbed.
Even Black Widow opened to $80 million,
and that came out when the only person going
to the movies was the unkillable psycho,
Tom Cruise. Can't believe I risked
getting COVID to go see "Black Widow."
But after Black Widow, things started to slip.
"Shang-Chi", not as much money. "Eternals," not
as much money. "Spider-Man," "Thor," and
"Black Panther" sequels got things back on
track a little – especially Spider-Man
even though that was mostly a gimmick.
I love you guys.
Outside of that success, the box
office totals kept getting smaller.
You mean shrinkage. Yes! Significant shrinkage!
People stopped showing up. If the choice was "see
another Marvel movie" or "get a second vasectomy,"
We are going to celebrate with the
mother of all cocktails, the vasectomy.
audiences would have chosen
the latter. I know I did.
It's a trend that ended up in box office disaster
for what is definitely not
“Captain Marvel 2”. I guess?
The first movie cracked the billion-dollar
mark, riding the wave of "Avengers" fever.
But in the lead-up to "The Marvels," the story
was about how low the opening weekend could go.
Presales were as bad as "The Flash" "The Flash!"
They didn't even put a baby in a microwave!
So "The Flash" was bad enough, with a $55
million domestic opening weekend. But now
here comes "The Marvels," racing it to the bottom.
Yeah, and it’s not like a competition.
The box office total for the movie's
opening weekend came in at a grand total of…
Are we sure this isn’t a DC movie?
But pretty devastating for "The
Marvels," and a disaster for the MCU.
One day you will find something
to make you feel this shitty.
The MCU has put out more than 33 movies
in the last 15 years. For context,
it took the "James Bond" franchise 60
years to produce 25. Shut up it is 25!
There is a useful four letter
word, and you are full of it.
Not all of those projects are must-sees – hello,
Eternals, Thor: Love and Thunder, and just about
every Disney + show. I don’t care what you say,
Rhodey wasn’t a Skrull at Tony’s funeral. But
"The Marvels" feels especially skippable, both for
fans of the franchise, and especially the general
audience. It's The Marvels, everybody! You know,
that team that doesn't even exist in the comics?
It feels like no one asked for this movie. We just
wanted X-Men and the Fantastic Four but no, here,
have The Marvels! …We made them up! This franchise
has not been able to justify its own existence,
despite putting out more content than ever
before. It's just new character after new
character standing around waiting for something
to happen, introducing and re-introducing the
Multiverse as a thing that exists. Oh,
and here's Kang, he got killed by ants.
In a series that's lost its purpose, "The Marvels"
feels inessential, mostly being marketed as a
goofy, fun team-up movie – and clearly, that's
not enough anymore. Fool me once, shame on you.
"Fool me – we can't get fooled again.”
It also doesn't help that critics were
mostly mixed on the movie itself. Looper
critic Self Promotion Anyone?!? Reuben
Baron gave the film a 7/10, but he couldn't help
but point out a lack of urgency or consequence.
What did we learn Palmer?
I don’t know Sir?
I don’t Fuckin know either!
He wrote,
"It's entertaining enough that you can't be
too bothered that it's barely about anything
and that it can't find the focus to really
commit to the things it's almost about."
"It's fine. It's just fine."
The bad reviews for "The Marvels"
call it things like "the worst Marvel
movie yet" - a "new low," "Abject misery,"
I don’t feel so good.
And even the positive reviews
use words like "fine", "generic", and "cluttered".
The two biggest positives that every review agrees
on are Iman Vellani's performance, and the brief
runtime of just over ninety minutes. That's right,
the fact that it's short is one of the best
things about it. That's how you describe a good
trip to renew your driver's license.
You'd think that a superhero movie
starring an Academy Award winner would do
better with the critics — but then again…
"I'm starting to get hungry… and you
don't wanna see me when I'm hungry."
Remember those dreams where you show up to class
only to realize that you hadn't studied for the
final? Also, you're in your underwear. "The
Marvels" is kind of like that. Despite being
a sequel to Captain Marvel, I guess, two
of the main characters are from shows on
Disney+ – one of which almost no one watched.
Kamala Khan, please come to my office ASAP.
You have done something very wrong.
The villain of the movie, Dar-Benn,
isn't exactly a Thanos-level threat. She's not
even Diet Hela – she's more of a Kroger-brand
Ronan the Accuser, minus, anything we liked about
Ronan the Accuser. Which is practically nothing.
What are you doing?
Her deal is revenge on
Brie Larson, but what for? Fast X? It happened
off-screen sometime after the first movie,
and it's entangled with the neverending
Kree-Skrull drama, which also had its own show.
Usually you only scratch the surface
of mediocrity. You must be finally
putting it all together. Well done!
Speaking of that, Nick Fury's here,
which first got teased all the way back in
"Spider-Man: Far From Home." How many hours
of content do you need to watch to understand the
plot of this "Captain Marvel" sequel? Would you
believe us if we said you also need to watch the
second-worst "X-Men" movie to understand the end?
Who's the furball?"
The fact that you need
to have seen so much to only sort-of
understand it is a major turn-off.
There’s a possibility. I
don’t think so Quin. Quil.
Marvel assumes that audiences will watch just
about everything leading up to this movie.
But now they're finding out that nobody likes
homework, and all that overconfidence is coming
back to bite them in the ass.
"That is America's Ass."
So what's next for the MCU? The
real question is, who cares?
I don’t care.
The most exciting storyline in
the franchise right now is Jonathan Majors' trial
— and unfortunately, She-Hulk probably won't be
showing up to save the day.
Ok, this was a mistake
Thankfully for Marvel, it seems they have a
bit of time to figure out what to do about
Kang. After "The Marvels," audiences will
have the likely Kang-free "Deadpool 3" and
"Captain America: Brave New World".
Captain Deadpool…. No, just Deadpool.
Once Phase Five is done, though, there
will be no escaping the Kang conundrum:
We should be dealing with a bigger problem
here. He who remains. I understand.
the next "Avengers" movie is literally named
after him. We couldn't be less excited.
"So let's stop wasting time!"
Marvel Studios has two more major cards to play:
"X-Men" and "Fantastic Four." After that, it'll
be nothing but sequels and spinoffs featuring
increasingly obscure characters.
Darren? Surprised to see me?
Some devoted comic fans would be delighted
to see Kevin Feige announce a Beta Ray Bill
movie for 2029, but most people would simply be
wondering who this ugly guy is and why he stole
Thor's armor. But who knows, maybe he'll show
up in "Secret Wars" alongside Roger Corman's
Fantastic Four and Lou Ferrigno's Hulk.
"AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAARGGGHHH!"
What we do know for sure is that Marvel Studios
really wants people to keep watching their movies,
and they're now officially trying to remind
you that you used to really like them.
Now this is all about making myself
creditable in your eyes again.
Case in point: the final trailer for "The
Marvels," which is a new level of desperation.
It starts with shots of characters that don't
appear in the movie – Never a good sign when
Marvel has to resort to clickbait. It
tries to imply a Thanos connection,
But it’s not over. My work is inevitable.
and otherwise tries to ride the Avengers
wave just like the first movie – but
this time, it didn't work.
Oh my god we are a team. Nope
Thanks to the 2023 SAG-AFTRA strike, which didn't
let actors work on or promote their projects,
the cast of "The Marvels" weren't allowed to
sell their film. That means no talk shows,
no Hot Ones, and no Wired Autocomplete. And no
Looper. For a movie that tried to sell itself on
the chemistry of its three leads, the only one
that could do an interview was the damn cat.
You did a great job cut away
The actors' strike came to an end on
November 9th — just one day before "The Marvels"
opened for Thursday showings. The actors are now
free to pay a visit to Jimmy Fallon to hype
up their movie — as long as they can tolerate
his never-ending laughter.
"Ha ha ha ha! Ha ha ha!"
Superhero fatigue is real, no matter what
Kevin Feige says, or how much he wants
to compare Marvel films to classic novels.
But don't forget, Kevin: most people prefer
books that are good. Reboot "Twilight." That
would be more fun than this at this point.
Anyway, a month after Feige said that
superhero fatigue is fake, "Quantumania"
came out to series-worst reviews.
I didn’t know he could do that.
The visuals, the writing, the heroes, the villain
– everything was underwhelming. People have
just gotten tired of these middling, low-effort
stories, and "The Marvels" didn't look like the
one that was going to win them back.
How does it look?
It doesn't matter that it stars Brie Larson
in a perpetual state of just remembering she
left her kid at the vape shop, or that it
also boasts a talented, diverse cast. It's
no wonder a movie called "The Marvels" didn't
do well at the box office – the Marvel name is
starting to mean it's kind of a waste of time.
Gotta say I sometimes miss that giddy optimism.